[Musique]
attendez il faut juste enlever les
micros s'il vous plaît des invités qui
viennent de sortir merci à vous en régie
de vous réveiller merci je vais pas
tarder à faire grève moi aussi merci si
vous voulez une carte je peux vous en
proposer grand plaisir c'est 1% du
salaire par contre ah tu vas pas le
faire il faut savoir qu'on va se battre
contre ça parce que c'est clairement une
remise en cause du droit de grève nous
ce qu'on dit c'est c'est malheureusement
on n'est plus dans un état droit de
liberté on est attaqué de façon frontale
sur notre droite grève mais on va pas se
laisser faire des files d'attente
interminables de plusieurs heures
souvent dans les grandes agglomérations
la pénurie de carburant devient
problématique comme le montre ces images
tournées dans le sud-ouest de Paris des
images montées en accéléré tant il y a
de véhicules 45% des stations services
sont en difficulté en Île-de-France
contre 31% au niveau national dans cette
cité de Créteil des jeunes ont mis en
place une station essence clandestine
tout au long de la journée il remplisse
les réservoirs des habitants des
communes alentours mais en début de
soirée les policiers procèdent un
contrôle
certains tentent alors de s'enfuir
il pensait profiter de la crise en toute
impunité dans le Val-de-Marne 5 suspects
d'une vingtaine d'années ont été arrêtés
à proximité de deux stations services
avec leur bidon c'est vendeurs à la
sauvette proposés aux automobilistes
dans la file d'attente du carburant à
3,50 € le litre ils ont été placés en
garde à vue quand des policiers
prioritaires passent devant tout le
monde pour remplir leur véhicule cela
grince des dents
que nous on attend on a tous un travail
la plupart des personnes qui sont là
c'est un peu tendu qu'est-ce que vous
faites dans la vie je suis inspecteur de
police
à la station essence
[Rires]
des abeilles se battent pour féconder
une femelle invisible au milieu de cette
boule ce cliché pris par une américaine
dans un ranch Texas vient de remporter
le prestigieux concours de photographie
animalière de l'année le musée
d'histoire naturelle de Londres a
également distingué un jeune thaïlandais
de 16 ans pour ce gros plan de la
mâchoire d'un organe parmi les laurés à
figure le français Laurent Ballesta pour
cette photo prise sous la glace de
l'Antarctique la forêt ça fait ah oui
mais vous êtes un grand spécialiste de
l'oiseau oui
mais comment la mettrieuse
[Musique]
il s'agit du nombre de vaches qui sont
concernés par une nouvelle taxe en
Nouvelle-Zélande elles sont plus de 6
millions 6,2 millions précisément et
leur P ont laissé désormais et bien
c'est un gros problème environnemental à
cause des gaz à effet de serre qui sont
émis donc une tarification unique au
monde cette taxe qui est très
controversée évidemment on tient génie à
Roanne si vous voulez savoir comment
péter son faire griller il donne la
technique
ça marche pas
et je vais vous laisser découvrir notre
dessert
[Musique]
alors appétissant
s'ils veulent t'arriver à tenir la
cadence nos pâtissiers amateurs doivent
savoir éviter les embûches ça passe pas
les bacs
ça va ou pas et ce n'est pas car elle
qui dira le contraire je peux comprendre
nationale
j'ai dit que les noirs sont mieux
traités en France
maintenant je me lance pour la science
voilà
[Musique]
c'est bizarre
je suis désolé mais dans le coupant
automatiquement je je me bouche le nez